[Music]
let's cheer it up a bit and let's go
into twitter hall of fame guys that's
the legendary twitter hall of fame final
fantasy xv
we haven't done twitter all hold a
family a little bit
i love twitter hall of fame sometimes
same same same same
right
star flight
i hate that you guys nipples don't work
because t head is comparable to head
head really
i mean yeah i knew that i knew that
already
but
i hear what she's saying because i have
no sensitivity in my nipples whatsoever
bro whatsoever so i can imagine
obviously ladies have a lot more
sensitive nipples than the mandem so i'm
so i know well compare it to my nipples
anyway because a nipple head is
comparable to head head but
i not necessarily not necessarily i see
it but sometimes
because you're when you're giving a head
to a girl right you're so far down you
can't really necessarily see her
reactions but you can kind of hear her
yeah yeah yeah but whereas when i'm
licking the t t head is yeah and you're
getting sucking on a nipple
you know she's in god the
my nipples are
little tickle cushions bro they're just
tickly i've got small nipples as well
i've got small nipples as well and a fat
tip i've got small nipples that have a
[ __ ] [ __ ] hefty teeth and just a
little ting on the edge yeah
i [ __ ] dark tic tac on the end that's
it
i ain't got an every other for [ __ ] bro
no areola oh that's it funny bro
oh [ __ ]
one guy wrote
if you're going to wear your hand in
front of your stomach the whole night
don't wear that outfit
[Laughter]
bro
yeah
facts
don't wear that outfit
after two months of talking i told this
guy yesterday that i wasn't ready for a
relationship and he responded it's been
great i hope you have a good one and
then he blocked me no effort no pressure
applied i'm devastated
raw is that what she's after fight me on
this
fight me on this [ __ ] you know she it
didn't pan out the way she wanted it to
sneaky links ask the most stupid
questions like why do you look so
nervous because i'm not supposed to be
with you what the [ __ ]
that's funny why do you look so nervous
when his phone is unlocked and you guys
are having a great day you just gotta
lock it for him
i like i want that as my screen saver
[Laughter]
i want that tweet as my screen saver
raw yes
so this is a mini
thread within a twitter hall of fame
that's not that many yeah so i saw this
tweet that said
what tricks do you guys be doing during
sex ladies share your trade secrets
quote tweet i i like to blindfold [ __ ]
and then right when he thinks we're
about to start [ __ ] i start swinging
on him
nah bro i can't explain the level of
fear that i'd be experiencing through
that brethren it's a different type of
sensation yeah no i'm not about it
i duct tape the dick and balls together
that way i can feel everything
[ __ ]
oh
ah she wrote i handcuff him and clear my
carts in peace using his credit cards of
course oh no i cleared my car
plural
in peace
[Laughter]
no bro
bro
one chick put
ah
first
first you pick a book of your choice
mine is the bible and then you read it
together one chick replied i don't think
my mind is going to come off that any
other ideas then another chick replied
mine is the karma sutra if you make it
to the end we ain't reading it right
facts facts facts
when i'm doing reverse cowgirl i like to
suck on his big toe and i'll bite it
when he's about to come if i can reach
nah bro
nah bro just let me not
i'm not nutting in converse cargo anyway
but yeah period
by away oh because i need to feel
satisfied right away
bite away from oh i need to be certain
else about this pain yeah but it's
curved pain
[ __ ] safe
all right that's the mini thread though
exactly
hall of fame
he doesn't have to post me as long as my
rent is paid on the first i don't give a
[ __ ]
fair
fair fairy that's a deal i'll be willing
to make
that's a deal i'd be willing to make
as long as my rent is paid on the first
i don't give a [ __ ] bet bet
say less
why people leave things in jesus hands
no means he's got holes in them is
beyond me
wow
dark
very dark
british people struggling in this heat
wave stay strong
your ancestors colonize entire countries
in this heat
[Laughter]
bro
fax there we go wow yeah old british
people were built different different
because if you think for one second
i'm pulling up into africa
into the congo
in this humidity and in trapping anyone
you've lost your mind you've lost your
mind you've literally lost your [ __ ]
brother jump in there it's boiling and
these men are wearing uniform on all
sorts every day every day shoulder pads
knives and everything
get me on the first ship back yeah
they're on stuff yeah [ __ ] these man
they were on stuff
dudes can eat dudes can't even unclip a
bra but can do everything else behind a
girl's back
raw
yeah raw
this reminds me of you
when you were working in sales every
time you say you got a payday
it's hard to save money when food is
always flirting with me
this sushi thing payday sushi payday
nigiri
yes bro i spend on food
i spend on food
if thames comes out as a mayonnaise
lover a mayonnaise man lover i will harm
innocent people
bro can you imagine if thames come out
and say i love white guys
i'll have nothing to say i'd have
nothing to say but it's the same
speeches that i have i'll have to say
about it i don't know why but that is
like to me that's like if mega stallion
came out and it's like i only [ __ ] white
guys
i'm never gonna [ __ ] you anyway i hear
you but for god's sake
for god's sake i thought i had a chance
yeah there is a reality in my head where
this might happen yeah yeah but now
you're firmly saying never mayonnaise
man you know raw
i begged my ex for almost three years
for something simple as flowers he
bought me flowers when we broke up
some commiseration
this is the reason why they say many
[ __ ]
yes because they're not stupid
they know what they're doing
of course of course
don't be the bigger person today be the
problem
toxic and that was a chick that said
that i know oh thanks
fake accounts are so funny because why
do you think i would follow back budgie
bantam 2-3-1
[ __ ]
[ __ ] butch
[Laughter]
oh wow
that's funny my co-worker started crying
because her boyfriend broke up with her
through through a text and my manager
said that's why we stay off our phones
at what
oh
my ex-girlfriend hit me up well sorry my
hex my ex-girlfriend hit on my new
girlfriend and told her i was a cheater
like damn why you gotta spoil the ending
i know you know how this is gonna end
but let her experience it
raw
fam
to be fair yeah like
that's never happened to me but when
i've heard those stories before i'm like
just leave her to find out you don't
even know her
you don't even [ __ ] know her relax
bro you're just it's under the guise of
being a good person you just want to
[ __ ] my life around yeah let me cheat if
i want to cheat
yeah
we're going to break hearts let me break
hearts this is the path i've chosen in
your life let me deal with this yeah
you're done according yeah [ __ ] off ah
this one time my side told me that my
mane was cheating on me
she
i'll let you finish drinking i will
start again
this one time my side told me that my
mane was cheating on me she even had
receipts i pretended like i knew and
didn't care i tried to stand up but my
knees failed me i just sat down and wept
to reciting
wrong imagine
i tried to stand up on my knees failed
me
yo
you know that's funny
mandem really can't
that our pride can't handle finding out
we've been cheated on we can't handle it
physically take it
we literally can't take it
i'm imagining it now we can't handle it
my side is telling me my man is cheating
on me and here are the receipts
oh
and he just sat there and cried
yo
bro imagine yeah you
mandom can't take it no matter what the
hypocrisy is yeah we can't take stuff
like that
i'm literally with i'm literally
cheating as we speak as we speak but i
can't find out that my girl's cheating
on me bro i can't
i'm breaking down
that's mandatory too oh [ __ ] i was so
jokes
fam this one
she blocked me
also
promise man had the audacity
to put this oh okay go go
she blocked me because she posted a
picture out of a plane window and i was
able to use the fact that it was a
virgin 737 flying north over the desert
cross referenced it with a flight radar
and the sun position to tell her the
flight number and the city she was going
to
she blocked him she blocked him oh rags
he's a psycho cracked
cracked did you hear ever um there was a
guy not long ago
who was
tracking
[ __ ] elon musk's like private jet or
something no fam
i don't know the details properly there
was a kid
a little while ago that was like
tracking elon musk's movements
for
fam for fun for fun just and just
posting it on twitter because he knew we
could do it yeah so he was just tracking
his [ __ ]
really really well
and just posting on twitter like elon
musk has landed in such and such today
it was getting so invasive and elon musk
is trying to pat he's a busy boy yeah
yeah he can't have man just knowing
where he's at
yeah he's got businesses to run yeah and
he's got competitors with his yeah he
can't be here in
he's landed in austin texas for this and
then he's in [ __ ] jamaica for this
yeah because couple man will start
adding up yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
so elon musk had to contact him and said
yeah well done
here's like give me a number stop yeah
i'll swear you paid him off i'll say
[ __ ] stop fair enough
and then boy's like saying less it took
the took the p and and dropped it
ndating hush hush yeah fair play fair
play props
all right i've got two more go go
[ __ ] be trying to suck dick all cute
if you don't start firming like a pit
bull i'm out
bro
we've said it before yeah there's either
a nut head yeah or there's like four
play head yeah if you're gonna try nut
head you best try and get this nut head
yeah yeah yeah yeah none of this like
cutesy
what was that one i said the other day i
don't want any more little little lizard
licks
bro
slop it like
the elixir of youth bro slop it like you
mean it's not be like you haven't sucked
a dick in 10 years suck it like you've
just come out pen yeah oh
suck it like you've just you just come
out
yes bro yes that's the [ __ ] bar
that is the bar you've just said ladies
suck it like you've just come out of pen
yeah yeah a ten year stretch a young
bird yeah yeah yeah and it's like the
first tool you grab onto yeah yeah yeah
demolish it right yeah yeah lap it up
that's what i want yeah rags that's what
i want wow that was such a good analogy
[ __ ] it yes bro
all right last one
i text my baby daddy is he bringing our
son back home
he says yeah i'm grabbing some food
first i'm like okay can you grab me
something this [ __ ] said
nah i can't be feeding nobody else's
girlfriend
this man hates my gut
bro
rags rags bro
i can't be feeding nobody else's
girlfriend
rags
right if you're not mine don't ask me
for stuff thanks bro absolutely facts
because you hold my u i'm just running
around for you shut up
but yeah that was uh this week's twitter
hall of fame thank you guys um thank you
so much you know what guys you i owe you
one because not a single bastard
complained about our short episode not
last week no one did true they took it
digested it commented and liked and you
guys are really really
really the [ __ ] tits thanks also on
top of that
uh me foreign spoke about today we saw
we noticed that you guys are really
really highly requesting a discord
server
so we're on it we're going to make a
happen patreon only sng discord server
yeah man enjoy that you do pay attention
to everything you guys say pay attention
to the feedback
um someone a few people have messaged me
before and uh ask for like a reddit page
uh or sub sg subreddit we actually have
one um a dedicated fan created one a few
months ago and he's just been lounging
in there collecting followers in there
so
uh i think it's like
uh it's shits and gigs i'm pretty sure
it's just shits and gigs so go on over
to reddit sheets and gigs sign up to
homeboy's uh subreddit for him he'll be
gassed and um as always guys love you
like a fat kid loves cake you know my
style i think anything to make you smile
[Music]
you